President Trump says he wants to move
forward and work constructively with
Russia after his g20 meeting with
President Vladimir Putin mr. Trump said
on Twitter that he questioned Putin on
election meddling and negotiated a
ceasefire in Syria but some members of
Congress objected when the president
tweeted Putin and I discussed forming an
impenetrable cybersecurity unit so that
election hacking and many other negative
things will be guarded Julianna
Goldman's at the White House where the
president now says that partnership may
not be a good idea what's behind the
change Julianna good morning good
morning well President Trump says he
wants to focus on areas where the US and
Russia can work together like on Syria
and cybersecurity but now he's under
fire from both Republicans and Democrats
for appearing to take sides with Russia
over his own intelligence agencies
president Trump raised a directive of
President Putin Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson on Sunday pushed back against
critics trying to ease concerns that
President Trump didn't challenge the
Russian President on their meddling in
the 2016 elections the point was made
that this is an issue that is really has
the American people quite concerned but
his interest on solution with the
Russian government saying mr. Trump
accepted Putin's denial over the weekend
White House surrogates tried to play
clean up President Trump still knows
that they meddled President Putin knows
that they meddled but he is never going
to admit to it the president defended
himself on Twitter explaining that Putin
vehemently denied that his country
interfered in the election and that he
has already given his opinion mr. Trump
added now it's time to move forward in
working constructively with Russia yes
it's time to move forward but there has
to be a price to pay
the olive branch to the Kremlin angered
some Republicans who also ridiculed the
president's suggestion that the u.s. and
Moscow may form a cybersecurity unit
this is like any other strategic
alliance but after the president touted
the possible partnership on Twitter mr.
Trump said there was a discussion but
that doesn't mean he thinks it can
happen senator marco rubio tweeted that
partnering with putin on a cybersecurity
unit is akin to partnering with assad on
a chemical weapons unit to forgive
forget when it comes to Putin regarding
cyberattacks instant power Putin for now
it's the White House's word against
Putin's president Trump did not hold a
customary news conference at the end of
the g20 summit and so he did not answer
any questions about his meeting with
Russia's president Charlie thanks
Julianna